okay i think magnus running out of ideas
here i'm surprised the evaluation bar is
only saying plus two for black because
that black pawn is so close to promotion
that is
too squares yeah now if the rook's come
off it's definitely not a draw anymore
there's no safety net there because
black's porn is destined to become a
queen and the promise doing something
very smart he's using his king to
blockade the motion the range of white's
bishop and uh
magnus is smiling yeah but uh i mean
that looked like an ironic smile and has
he just resigned i think he's just
resigned black was about to make a new
queen that black pawn is going to cost
white the rook maybe magnus missed
something i'm not sure what it was
though because that was very logical
played by black and there we go the
world champion loses for a second game
in a row wow kudos to jana pomnyachi
though i mean obviously it's not
the big revenge after uh losing the
world championship match but a great
game by him yep a great game